So here we are.
Well,
so I made a case tonight.
I'll go over it.
What's the case?
The postmodernist are wrong.
They're philosophically naive.
They're right about an infinite number
of interpretations and wrong about a
finite number of viable
interpretations and that's like that's,
that's death.
That's the end of postmodern is theory
and that's not the only way in which
they're wrong.
They're wrong in a bunch of other ways,
but they're more subsidiary.
The Marxists,
they're not just wrong,
they're wrong and murderous or wrong,
murderous and genocidal.
Unless you think murderers and
genocidal doesn't mean wrong and you,
you can think that there's lots of would
be revolutionaries who would be happy
to have blood running in the street if
they had their chance for revenge and the
opportunity to move up the
hierarchy of tyranny so you can,
you don't have to think that
murder and genocide is wrong,
especially if the right people
are murdered in genocide,
right?
That's actually part of it,
part of the whole equation.
But if you're willing to think that
murder and genocide on a mass scale across
many cultures,
over many decades is wrong,
then Marxism is wrong.
And the postmodernist don't
get to just come along.
And a dog Marxism as a matter of sleight
of hand because they're Marx's theory
didn't work out and they
figured out a rationalization.
They don't get to get away with
that because it's too dangerous.
It's too dangerous to the rest of us,
and we don't.
And it isn't necessary for us who are
trying with the small part of our hearts
that might be oriented towards the good
to allow people who are manipulating us
with historical ignorance
and philosophical sleight
of hand to render us so God
damn guilty about what our
ancestors may or may not have done.
So that we allow our
shame and our guilt to be,
to be used as tools to manipulate us into
accepting a future that we do not want
to have.
And that's that
[inaudible].